it's taken 6 000 years for nature to
carve these remarkable formations
the marble caves of chile chico are
located on a peninsula of solid marble
bordering a remote glacial lake that
spans the chile argentina border
the lake is fed by rivers coming from
several surrounding glaciers
as the glaciers melt and grow the waters
slowly carve out the marble leaving
behind masterpieces fit for a museum
these distinct bright blue waters are
caused by suspended particles from the
glaciers reflecting the blue part of
sunlight
getting to this location isn't easy it's
a long journey requiring a flight a 200
mile drive into the wilderness and a
boat ride just to get there
but it's worth it
the remarkable swirling patterns on the
cave reflect the lake's blue waters
changing with the water levels and the
season
nature truly is the greatest artist
in the middle of the harsh desert in
peru surrounded by miles of rolling sand
dunes there's a small oasis that's far
from a mirage
the town of wakachina has a population
of about 100 people and is one of the
few remaining natural oases in north and
south america
it's a popular tourist destination
hosting tens of thousands of tourists
each year
in its heyday the village flourished as
an elite resort getaway for the wealthy
who once flocked to the waters of the
lagoon because it was thought to have
medicinal properties
the resort became so popular it is even
featured on peru's official currency
legend holds that the lagoon was created
when a beautiful native princess was
apprehended at her bath by a young
hunter she fled
leaving the pool of water she had been
bathing in to become the lagoon and the
woman herself is rumored to still live
in the oasis as a mermaid
stepping onto socotra island is like
setting foot on an alien landscape
this place is one of the most isolated
landforms on earth located in the
arabian sea south of yemen the islands
separated from the mainland of africa
between six and seven million years ago
there are nearly 700 endemic species on
sakotra that are found nowhere else on
the planet
perhaps the most head-turning of
socotra's species is the dragon's blood
tree
these strange umbrella-shaped trees dot
the island
its top-heavy design is actually an
adaptation to socotra's arid climate the
large green crown provides shade which
reduces evaporation in a place that sees
very little rainfall
this otherworldly gem has experienced
threats to its ecology from human
development but the united nations
stepped in in 2008 designating it a
unesco heritage site
in the heart of myanmar's jungles over 1
000 pagodas can be found piercing
through the green
niang oak and the crumbling ruins of
schwe in theon are home to these sacred
buildings all at various stages of
preservation
some have been restored
and others are still in their original
crumbling state
they're decorated with images of
celestial beings or mythological animals
such as the naga serpents and lion-like
chintz
some enshrine images of the buddha
the site is believed to date back to the
days of the indian emperor ashoka who
sent monks in the 3rd century bc to
spread buddhism across asia
but it wasn't until around the 14th
century that construction began on these
buildings and most weren't finished
until 400 years later
local buddhists are now attempting to
salvage and restore these ancient
structures
however some will inevitably be lost to
the jungle
m.c escher has nothing on this place
chan baori is one of the largest and
perhaps most visually spectacular
stepwells
this deep four-sided structure is made
up of 3 500 escherase terraced steps
that descend down to a depth of 100 feet
a large temple adorns the face dedicated
to harshat mata
goddess of joy and happiness
you may recognize this incredible wonder
its intricate steps have made
appearances in hollywood films like the
fall the dark knight rises and the best
exotic marigold hotel
northwestern india where the stepwell
lies is extremely arid the well was
designed to conserve as much water as
possible
at the bottom of the well the air
remains five degrees cooler than at the
surface making it an excellent gathering
place for locals during intense heat
waves
so
jodhpur india is a sea of blue in the
middle of a hot dry desert
welcome to the blue city
jodhpur is the second largest city in
india's rajasthan province
surrounded by a wall with bastions the
striking blue buildings and jodhpur
contrast sharply and beautifully with
the neighboring tar desert
it's the older quarters built in 1459
where many of the blue buildings are
found
some say the color is associated closely
with the brahmins india's priestly cast
and the blue houses of the old city
belong to families of that cast
there's also an argument that termites
are the real reason
builders added copper sulfate to the
whitewash to thwart the pests which
resulted in the eye soothing blue
however locals say the blue is a natural
indigo dye
a final explanation might be the city's
nickname it's known as the sun city
and the blue helps keep the homes cool
either way john poor looks like a
real-life fairy tale
the goblin valley state park in utah is
known for its thousands of hudu rocks
referred to locally as goblins
hoodoos are formations of
mushroom-shaped sandstone and goblin
valley has the highest occurrences of
these in the world
it is often compared to mars because its
look
is otherworldly
in northern lithuania near the city of
chile
hundreds of thousands of crosses sit on
a hill
now representing both the lithuanian
identity and christian devotion
this site of pilgrimage offers peace to
those who visit
this is the hill of crosses
the tradition of leaving crosses began
in 1831 to commemorate those who had
fallen in a rebellion against russia
people still leave crosses today
you